[Music]
Dynamic web apps are everywhere in
today's internet built with different
Frameworks across multiple programming
languages for Java developers the spring
boot framework is widely used to quickly
develop Dynamic web apps with
functionalities such as Auto
configuration intended to help
developers build and ship faster but of
course Dynamic web apps need somewhere
to run somewhere to store data some way
to return static content to have to
learn these bits from scratch in the
cloud may be antithetical to the whole
point of spring boot that's why we're
excited to announce a jumpstart solution
designed to provision on your behalf
Cloud resources that a Java based
Dynamic web app needs on Google Cloud
all in a matter of minutes
now if this is your first time hearing
of a jumpstart solution they're a
package Google Cloud resource that can
be quickly deployed directly from the
Google Cloud console if you'd like to
make changes to the solution we've also
built the foundation of these Solutions
in terraform which you can pull locally
and customize to your liking and while
they're not intended for production use
out of the box they do contain patterns
that can be adopted as you prepare your
own Java Dynamic web app for production
in Google cloud in this solution we're
deploying point of sale as our Dynamic
web application simulating one you might
see in a brick and mortar retail store
point of sale is made up of three
microservices each written in Java using
the spring boot framework let's dive
into the solutions architecture
as the user accesses the point of sale
app running in Google Cloud they'll
first have their HTTP requests handled
by a Google Cloud load balancer this
load balancer routes traffic to our
point of sale web app which is made up
of a few Services running in a Google
kubernetes engine autopilot cluster
configured via a kubernetes service the
load balancer distributes traffic across
kubernetes pod replicas of the point of
sale API server service
this API server serves static assets to
the end user while also communicating
with inventory and payment services to
dynamically show users products and
process payments respectively these
Services also run as kubernetes pods the
app's products are stored in a cloud
spanner database before being served
dynamically this is the fundamental
architecture of the point of sale web
app however Beyond providing runtime
networking and staple resources this
solution also implements a few practices
worth highlighting first our Google
kubernetes engine cluster is an
autopilot cluster this means that Google
owns the life cycle of the entire
cluster pre-configured with recommended
practices around security and auto
scaling
second Cloud Trace is instrumented so
that we can view latency between
Services helping us identify and
remediate bottlenecks
upon deployment of this jumpstart
solution you'll be able to access the
point of sale app simulate user requests
interact with its underlying
infrastructure and adopt learnings for
your own Java based Dynamic web app
so what now as I mentioned each of these
Solutions are accessible in the Google
Cloud console if you navigate to
products and solutions and then
jumpstart Solutions you can navigate to
the solution and deploy it with a few
clicks you can also reference our
solution guides to dig deeper into the
architecture and learn about customizing
the solution
finally you can also explore using our
interactive tutorials that walk you
through the various components of the
solution
foreign
[Music]
check out the links below to try this
jumpstart solution yourself
[Music]